blaze miss congratulations guys you're
both moving to the third and final round
of this fortune fire challenge now in
this round we're gonna ask you to go
back to your home forges for four days
and while you're there you're gonna be
building another blade from the mind of
ben abbott
all right placements i'd love to rise to
a challenge and i sincerely hope you do
too because what i'm about to ask you to
make is this
my sutton who's sword
the sutton hoo sword traces its roots
back to seventh century england named
for the burial site in suffolk where it
was discovered
this fierce double-edged blade was light
enough to be wielded one-handed
delivering deadly splashes and stabs
against opponents
this intricate weapon was previously
feasted on forged in fire when dave
baker challenged me to build it during
the judge's home forge battle
where i spent almost two weeks forged
welding together twisted damascus steel
to create the complex damascus design so
guys good luck you've got a very
difficult challenge ahead of you we will
see you in four days let's go
all right man do it
my name is josh adams 36 years old from
castelia ohio and i'm a security
contractor and part-time bladesmith i
really enjoy taking raw materials and
making them into something that people
admire and enjoy and can use it's a
great stress reliever too
the billet is in the forge
i'm working on handle pieces doing a
little work here and there i think that
worked pretty good and i come back over
to the forge
oh no
i left the
billet in the forest too long and just
burned up i'm gonna start over from
scratch is what it is plan b
that's why
i have a backup plan this 1060.
so i grabbed my 1060 should have been
plan a
end of the challenge
even though i tried with the damascus
and it didn't work out i still made the
sword and i'm extremely pleased with it
i feel there's nothing else that i can
do to it at this point i'm excited to
see it get used and tested
my name is jared irby i'm 38 years old
i'm from dallas fort worth texas i'm a
driver engineer paramedic for a fire
department in north texas i'm fortunate
enough that my fire department job pays
the bills so the money i make from the
knives that i build gives me the
opportunity to give a couple thousand
dollars a year to kids cancer research
this thing's got to get heated up and
then we're going to quench it
there's any number of things that can go
wrong there we go
any one of those would be catastrophic
it didn't shatter into a million pieces
so i'd say that we're doing about as
good as we can
i'm a little bit relieved but it's not a
warm and fuzzy kind of a feeling there's
still lots of handle parts to work on
the pommel on this sword is big and it's
heavy and so i need to figure out an
effective way to secure it and fasten it
to the rest of the blade and i also need
to kind of work on balance and what
that's going to do with the performance
epoxy pins and i can get ready for the
last bit of assembly i'm very happy with
how it ended up i gave it everything
i've got i made it as structurally sound
and as ornately fashioned as i could
it looks pretty good
i'm glad that i've got something that
i'm happy with and i'm just ready for it
to get tested and let's just see what
happens
bladesmiths welcome to the keel test
to find out how lethal your weapons are
i'm gonna take your weapons deliver some
lethal blows on this wild boar carcass
jared you're up first you ready for this
yes sir all right let's do this
all right charles talk about your sutton
who sword here
first up it is a massive beast there's a
lot of weight to this now this is a very
thick and hairy wild boar so the cuts
are deep despite all that here
overall sir your weapon
it will kill thank you
all right josh your turn so you ready
that's why i'm here let's go
[Music]
nice job man
all right josh your edge
is sharp as you can see
it cut the pig in half
overall sir your sudden who
you'll keel
thank you
blade smiths welcome to the strength
test the enemy shield chop
i'm going to be using your sutton who
swords to chop into these enemy shields
jared your first you ready yes sir cool
great job bud thank you
all right jared
subtlest of things on this handle these
rivets are still a little sharp you know
they need to be peened over a little
more so on the base of my hand i was
getting a little bit of rubbing
your blade
has taken small rolls but in general
this held up really well i think you did
a great job making a sudden who sword so
nice job thank you
all right josh you're up you ready do
work
all right josh your handle i think you
did a really great job i think that the
artistry in here is beautiful
as for blade damage there's a couple of
small rolls but in general i think he
did a great job thank you
[Music]
all right bladesmith this is the
sharpest test the animal hides slice
jared you're up first you ready for this
yes sir let's do this
all right jared's talking about your
weapon here
so as you see when i'm cutting the hide
this area right here is quite sharp but
this area right here that took some
rolling or damage during the strength
test just isn't quite sharp and it skips
but overall sir you will cut thank you
all right josh your turn so you ready
send it let's do this
nice job man
all right josh let's talk about your
weapon here
you have a wicked grind over here
because even on the areas that took some
rolling it's still razor sharp
on the cuts here it's like hot knife
through butter overall sir
your sword
you will cut thank you
all right guys so you came to this forge
to show the world you have what it takes
is blade smith to win the title of
fortune fire champion and get a check
for ten thousand dollars and i gotta say
both of you set the bar extremely high
with your swords and i know ben is very
proud of your work you should be too but
guys at the end of the day only one of
you can take the title
judges have made a final decision
today's force and fire champion is
is josh congratulations man
now jared you're an extremely talented
smith but unfortunately you're not going
home with the win today your time this
competition has ended i'm gonna have to
ask you to please step off the forge
floor thank you all very much
i'm happy with what i made i did my very
best but uh i don't think there's any
question that his blade performed better
all around
all right josh congratulations man
you're the newest fortune fire champion
and you got yourself a check for ten
thousand dollars congratulations
how do you feel
good i feel relieved blessed and
ecstatic that i just won you have plans
for the money i get the title god gets
the glory wife gets a patio wife gets a
patio i had a blast performing under the
pressure meeting new people if anybody's
thinking about doing this
try it out it really was a lot of fun
you